it is hard to find comfortable t-shirts
shirts made of supima cotton are the
softest you will find under one percent
of t-shirts are made with supima cotton
and the Leisure of NYC is the place to
find them you'll get 15 off their silky
smooth t-shirts and boxers at
davidpackman.com
NYC the link is down below
I have no choice but to admit that we
have a remarkable economic situation
right now the situation is not that we
will never again have a recession in
fact we almost certainly will unless
something changes permanently about the
type of economy that we have at some
point there will be a recession uh or
worse because that's the way that things
have worked for a very long time but
when we look at the latest inflation
numbers and we look at all of the other
data that we have it is quite an
extraordinary situation we have new
inflation numbers out today it's July so
the numbers are from June and for the
12-month period ending in June of 2023
and year-over-year inflation is down to
three percent
three percent I have been talking about
for over a year now I've been saying I
believe that by August of 23 inflation
will be down to the low fours or the
high threes which would be a dramatic
improvement from where it was a year and
a half ago
I don't know anything it was just my
sense of the direction things were going
and I actually was too conservative in
my estimate inflation consumer prices in
June Rose at slowest annual rate since
March of
2021. according to the latest data from
the Bureau of Labor Statistics now these
right Wingers who just don't like these
numbers will say you can't believe these
numbers that's not real okay well when
when you like the numbers you believe
the numbers from the Bureau of Labor
Statistics and now they'll go oh but
eggs are expensive I saw the other day
uh we don't judge these numbers by what
one person sees in one grocery store
this is actually a metric that is
extraordinarily detailed and nuanced the
Consumer Price Index went up 0.2 percent
last month and that prior year number it
is now a three percent increase a three
percent increase as of last month we had
a four percent year-over-year increase
we are now down to a three percent
year-over-year increase these are really
good numbers and it is not just
inflation in a vacuum that looks really
good and I'll come back to what we mean
when we say inflation looks good wages
are rising and are now higher than they
were before the pandemic inflation
adjusted again the detractors the the
the Maga pessimists will say well sure
nominally wages are higher but
inflation's been crazy no no no no
inflation-adjusted wages real wages are
now higher than they were before the
pandemic if you look at the G7 countries
the U.S has the lowest inflation of all
of them if you look at gas prices gas
prices are now down about a buck 50 a
gallon the unemployment rate is at 3.6
percent that is under four percent for
the longest stretch in 50 years 50 years
and of course they will come back and
they will say oh but a lot of these are
low quality jobs or a lot of people have
stopped looking for work these are
always things that can be said it's the
way these metrics work you can't only
say that when it's to your advantage
these are the real numbers now let's
talk about inflation a little bit I want
to remind you that the target for
inflation is not zero the target for
inflation is considered to be two
percent we're basically there we're at
three percent the target is two percent
so we're getting down to an inflation
level that is what you would want for
what would be considered by traditional
economic measures a good inflation
number let me remind you why and I know
that there are people who have heard me
say this before but I do think it's it's
such an important basic economic concept
to understand that I want to explain it
again if inflation is really high we
know why that's bad people can't afford
stuff if inflation is eight percent and
wages are only up two percent Things
become unaffordable so people stop
buying them which is bad for businesses
so businesses have to lay people off and
then the people they lay off don't have
money to buy things so then more
businesses have to lay people off so a
very high inflation it's pretty
self-evident why that's bad some people
might say well shouldn't we want zero
inflation or even deflation prices
coming down it'd be so great everybody
can afford what they want
wrong
if there is a deflationary situation you
would expect things to be cheaper in the
future than they are now and so save for
absolute Necessities like food you need
food to survive
if you expect prices to be lower in the
future you would delay economic activity
if I'm looking at a car and I say well
the car is going to be three percent
cheaper in six months I wouldn't buy it
and it has a similar effect as things
being unaffordably expensive which is
you're not buying and that's bad for
businesses they lay off workers and you
have the same thing the reason that by
traditional economic measures we say two
percent inflation roughly is what we
want
is that that two percent inflation is
what drives economic growth uh and
expansion now of course when we step out
of this traditional economic analysis we
say well the planet is of limited size
and resources you can't have indefinite
growth and that is also theoretically
true and in some sense it's practically
true before we get to that point we may
be off to mining asteroids or who knows
what so it starts to get a little
theoretical and philosophical but that's
the reason why a little bit of inflation
is considered good I also want to remind
you there are many aspects to inflation
that have nothing to do with the
president so I'm not here to tell you
we're going to Bow and pray at the altar
of Joe Biden that because of what we're
seeing much the same way that it wasn't
exclusively Trump's fault that inflation
was high there are many aspects to
inflation that don't relate to the
president this includes changes to the
money supply supply and demand shocks
like for example you know natural
disasters coveted whatever the case may
be
expectations about inflation become
self-fulfilling prophecies these things
are bigger than the president and
remember inflation's coming down in all
G7 countries but it's coming down more
in the United States what presidents can
do is fiscal policy like government
spending taxation Etc and indirectly
monetary policy remember the president
doesn't control monetary policy directly
the FED does but the president does
decide who is in charge at the Fed so no
reason to play political games no reason
to sugarcoat or to do sky is falling
stuff these numbers are what they are
they only slightly relate to Joe Biden
but this is a good sign overall doesn't
mean it's a perfect economy doesn't mean
there won't be a downturn at some point
in the future Chris Christie the former
Republican governor of New Jersey
continues to pound Trump again and again
and again and he's saying a lot of
things that make sense but it doesn't
seem to be helping his poll numbers
which we are going to look at I like
these Chris Christie interviews because
they are just a reminder that even
though he's corrupt and even though I
don't agree with him on so much when it
comes to policy he's operating in the
real world and Republicans can operate
in the real world they often choose not
to but they can let's listen to Christy
giving his thoughts on what he believes
is in Trump's mind about these criminal
cases that he is up against this was
from an MSNBC interview yesterday part
of what the Department of Justice has
always done under all of the Attorneys
General that I've seen in my lifetime is
if we offer you a plea which I'm certain
they will and you turn it down and you
take us to trial
and you're convicted that judge is
sending you to jail and I think that's
what he goes to bed every night thinking
every night and all this bravado and
everything else I've known him for 22
years and when I was doing these cases
in New Jersey and I would put political
figures in jail
he would say to me I could never do that
I could never go to jail and I'm telling
you no matter what he says no matter how
he's bragging and and going on and on
about him not being afraid he goes to
bed every night thinking about the sound
of that jail cell door climbing closing
behind them so the point of all that
really is to say when push comes to
shove
I'm not so sure he won't take the play
all right and by the way Trump taking a
plea would be just an un I'm not even
ready to seriously have that
conversation yet even though Trump's
already been arrested twice and possibly
will be again in multiple trials and all
that I'm not even ready to have that
conversation because it's just it's
mind-blowing to think about the failed
former president taking a plea but
that's Chris Christie's perspective
Chris Christie also weighing in on why
he sees Trump as a danger to the country
of course it would have been nice for
Chris Christie to skip the four years of
sucking up to Trump and go directly to
this he didn't do that for four years he
sucked up and he said positive things
but at least he's saying it now do you
think it's a danger to the country well
I don't want him to be president so yeah
I mean you know the fact is that he's a
guy who has shown over the course of
time and even more particularly I'd say
mike in his post-presidency true that he
is detached from reality in this respect
he continues to say and he said this the
other day in response to question what
Brett Baer asked him you know how are
you going to win back to Suburban Women
Voters that you lost in 2020 to Joe
Biden and he said first off I didn't
lose in 2020. so we don't need a
candidate as Republicans who's going to
continue to look backwards and try to
re-fight the 2020 election he's even
even in the race he won in 2016. he's
trying to refine the Nevada election and
imagine saying that interview yesterday
in Nevada he called it a disgraceful
State well that's an interesting
approach to trying to win their
electoral votes by the way you people
are disgraceful uh vote for me please I
mean
listen Chris Christie is right but sadly
it's not trans sadly for him it's not
translating to polling support if we
look at the latest averages of recent
polling Trump's still between 52 and 53
de sanctimonious is at 21.
and Chris Christie is at 2.5 2.5 yes 150
increase over the one percent where he
found himself some time ago but it is
not going to be enough to get him that
nomination we'll continue following
Chris Christie and everybody's campaigns
I'm gonna play a clip for you here of a
trump supporter talking about
homelessness now homelessness is a very
important issue homelessness is a moral
failing of the United States there's no
reason we have to have homelessness in
the United States there's also no reason
we have to have hunger but we lack a
political will and sort of resolution to
decide we're not going to do it anymore
but this is interesting here is a trump
supporter
complaining about homelessness she says
something very interesting she says she
doesn't see Hispanics out on the street
she sees blacks and whites what does she
mean by this what's the truth of it and
what the hell is going on here let's
listen it has been some of the negative
things since the Biden
you turn your head and you pause for
dramatic effect but me too to be honest
with you yeah I've never seen so many
homeless in my life ever never in my
life have I ever seen so many homeless
and it's like okay we're gonna take
we're gonna have open borders I never
see any of the Hispanics on the street
what I see is African-American and
Caucasian American
what is she trying to make in terms of a
point here
I I don't is the point she's trying to
make that Hispanics or hard workers and
they don't end up homeless or something
like is she is this Praise of Hispanic
Americans Hispanic I what point is she
trying to make now the the math is sort
of interesting in reality it's estimated
that about 24 of those who were homeless
in 2022 were Hispanic and that's that's
an over-representation relative to the
19 of the population that Hispanics are
believed to make up so 19 of the
population 24 of homeless Hispanics are
over represented in the homeless
population I but I don't know what that
proves one way or the other just as
usual these folks are wrong on the facts
and their analysis and commentaries is
weird now I do want to mention how do
people end up homeless because there is
this idea among many on the right that
when you're homeless it's the result of
a personal failure I actually was at a a
restaurant the other day there was a guy
there with his daughter and also his his
girlfriend it clearly wasn't the the
daughter's mom it was it was his
girlfriend and with his daughter and I
overheard this guy saying if you're
hungry in this country it's by choice
and then five minutes later he yelled at
his daughter and then later at his
girlfriend very loudly in front of a
restaurant full of people it was super
cringy so that's that guy is the one who
was saying if you're hungry in this
country it's by choice the truth is that
homelessness in the United States is
often the result of structural factors
poverty lack of affordable housing major
issue not enough housing unemployment
low wages discrimination domestic
violence mental illness substance abuse
abuse lack of social support all of
those things can affect anybody
regardless of race ethnicity gender age
or background but it is true that there
are historically marginalized
communities that are more likely to be
affected by some of those issues one
other thing there's this myth that
homeless people are lazy or dangerous uh
this is also not true as far as lazy uh
the the vast majority of the poor and
many of the homeless actually do work
that's number one and then number two uh
this idea of criminality homeless
criminality the vast majority of
homeless people have never committed any
criminal act other than if a city makes
it a crime to be homeless then you were
criminalizing their very uh status and
we've talked about that happening in a
number of different cities so not sure
what point this woman was trying to make
but at least it gives us an opportunity
to talk about homelessness let's take a
quick break we'll be right back
often I have to wear shirts for a long
time before the material softens and
feels good on my skin but if you want a
t-shirt that's actually super soft right
when you open the package brand new
check out our sponsor Leisure of NYC
T-shirts from Leisure of NYC are made
with supima cotton that's an Ultra
Premium species of cotton known for
feeling better than any other t-shirt
Fabric and way more durable under one
percent of men's t-shirts are made with
supima cotton also check out the boxer
briefs made from moisture wicking
viscose from bamboo which will bring you
a level of comfort you didn't even know
was possible with underwear these boxer
briefs feel like air and they don't
Bunch up all of their products are fair
trade produced using sustainable methods
when you buy the scratchy cheaply made
t-shirts and boxers you end up spending
more in the long run but once you do it
right with t-shirts and boxers that feel
silky smooth from day one they will last
you for years to come you'll get 15 off
everything in their store at
davidpackman.com NYC the link is below
I will very briefly remind you that the
David packman show is an audience
supported program we primarily depend on
people who get a membership at
joinpakman.com we package up a whole
bunch of great goodies for those that do
including the world famous and
award-winning bonus show yeah it's
Awards we've completely made up and we
were the only people in the in the
running for but still they are Awards
you can sign up at joinpakman.com and
use the coupon code 24 starts now you
can also get the children's critical
thinking book now over 5 000 copies sold
at davidpackman.com book remember to
leave a review if you've purchased the
book over the last week or so let's take
a look at the continued downfall of Ron
DeSantis the Republican Florida governor
who is polling about 20 percent in the
Republican primary more than everybody
but Trump but with seemingly no path to
actually securing the Republican nominee
Nation Ron DeSantis was interviewed by
Fox news's Stuart Varney or Fox
businesses Stuart Varney this is a
kafka-esque moment I apologize I
apologize it is kafka-esque uh Stuart
Varney mentions to DeSantis listen
you're down over 30. how are you going
to catch up what's your strategy and
DeSantis just attacks the media I don't
know that this strategy has winner
written all over it you're down over 30
points to Trump what's your strategy for
catching up
well first I think it's pretty clear
that the media does not want me to be
the candidate I think that they've tried
to create narratives that somehow the
race is over this is going to be a
state-by-state contest we've worked
really hard to build the type of
organization in places like Iowa New
Hampshire South Carolina that you need
to actually be able to win these early
contests and we're going to continue
doing that we got a lot of work but
we've had very very favorable uh
response and we're going to keep
building off that momentum at the end of
the day I think the fact that I'm the
one that's targeted by the media by the
left even by the president of Mexico
listen if the strategy is I'm going to
pretend to be a victim just like trump
it pretends to be a victim I guess he's
doing it but I don't know that this is
going to get him too many votes because
people know that I will beat Biden and
they know that I will actually deliver
on all these issues and beat the
Democrats at the border beat up folks
this is really low energy you're down 30
to Trump what's your stress strategy for
catching up well it's mostly the media's
fault but I'm gonna beat Biden well
you're not even gonna face Biden unless
you figure out a way to make up a
30-point gap on Donald Trump if I want
to be as charitable as possible to Ron
DeSantis he seems to be saying when he
says it's a state-by-state contest 30
points nationally don't matter if I can
win Iowa and or New Hampshire and
justify staying in this race it's not
looking like he can win Iowa or New
Hampshire but let's put that aside if I
want to generously say that's a strategy
okay I guess that's a strategy which is
forget about the national polling just
focus on those critical States during
this disastrous interview Stuart Varney
actually asks DeSantis
is there is is there any climate plan
that you have listen to what he says the
headlines are just full of stories about
wildfires smoke extraordinary
temperatures in the southwest and the
southeast to some degree do you have a
climate plan
it's going to be to rip up Joe Biden's
Green New Deal I think at the end of the
day we need to embrace American domestic
energy this could be a huge source of
National Security economic Vitality it
can build our industrial base in Florida
we've actually had a huge reduction in
emissions but it was done through
Innovation it was done through Market
forces not command and control so we'll
go about that in a much different
direction now you might be surprised
about hearing that he's going to do away
with Joe Biden's Green New Deal and the
reason you might be surprised is there
is no green New Deal now if you press
them on this and you say the green New
Deal isn't the law what do they say they
usually say something like well Joe
Biden has integrated elements of the
green New Deal into the inflation
reduction act as well as by executive
order but then if you really press them
it's very difficult to actually make
that uh a believable
um a believable argument so as I've said
before not ready for prime time does not
have winner written all over him has
absolutely no tangible explanation as to
how he's going to make up the 30-point
deficit and he's only running against
Joe Biden and the funny thing is he's
running against Joe Biden and against
things Joe Biden hasn't actually done
you've got to figure out a way to win
one state here bro and it's not clear
that he's figured that out and meanwhile
there are problems in Florida Trouble in
Paradise let's talk about that next
there's an additional problem for Ron
DeSantis and the problem is that there
is a malaria outbreak in Florida
now you might be saying David that
really is very little to do with Ron
DeSantis and there's also some cases in
Texas and but there is a very specific
reason why this is a problem for Rhonda
sandis and we're going to talk about
that Newsweek reports Ron DeSantis under
pressure as Florida malaria cases spread
uh the article reads DeSantis is facing
pressure amid a growing number of
malaria cases in Florida after reports
emerged that two Public Health roles
related to combating the spread of
disease have been left vacant for months
two more cases of the mosquito-borne
disease were detected in Sarasota County
to the south of Tampa according to the
latest disease monitoring report this
brings the total number of cases
contracted inside the U.S this year to
six in Florida the county along with
Manatee County and Miami-Dade are now
under alert this is the first time in
two decades that the disease caused by a
parasite has been locally acquired
rather than linked to international
travel the one reason why this is
related to Rhonda sandis and bad for
Rhonda santis is because there are two
Public Health roles related specifically
to combating the spread of disease
that have been left vacant for months
now you can make the argument even with
those two roles you're not going to
prevent six cases of malaria and I'm
with you I don't know that you are going
to prevent six cases of malaria because
you fill two rules that are empty but
this is another example of the disregard
and the indifference to properly
Staffing these roles related to health
Florida's been having problems with this
they have that wacky uh Dr ladapo uh
anti-vax cookie doctor at the helm
during covid firing the woman who was
putting together that Cova dashboard all
of these different things so it makes
them look terrible now let's talk about
malaria a little bit malaria is a
mosquito-borne disease it doesn't only
affect humans it can affect other
animals it's caused by a parasite which
is transmitted by the bytes of infected
mosquitoes when the mosquito becomes
infected and then bites an infected
person
and then goes and bites a non-infected
person the mosquito is is spreading the
disease the parasite enters the person's
bloodstream goes to the liver infects
red blood cells now malaria is usually
not directly contagious from person to
person unless there's contact of
infected blood
organ transplant blood transfusion
theoretically uh you know two open
wounds touching each other although it's
it's it's rare So person-to-person
transmission is not common it can be
transmitted during uh pregnancy or
delivery and so when you say how
contagious is malaria what's the r
number it's sort of unclear the research
I did said it could be under one all the
way up to a hundred depending on the
setting and it's such a small number of
cases that we see in the United States
in this way that it's actually difficult
to put a number on it diagnosed by a
blood test that can detect the presence
of the parasite malaria is treated with
anti-malarial drugs such as chloroquine
methylaquin and Other Drugs depends on
the severity depends on the type if it
is untreated can cause severe
complications and death including
complications can include swelling of
the brain fluid in the lungs organ
failure and
a low blood sugar coma or death
ugly ugly stuff the first approved
vaccine for malaria uh is known by the
brand name mosquarex and as of a few
months ago it's been given to about a
million and a half kids living in parts
of the world that have moderate to high
malaria transmission our six cases in
Florida reason to panic they are not are
six cases in Florida when there are two
open positions thanks to Ron DeSantis a
political problem for him potentially uh
very much so all of these stories we
will have follow-up discussion and
you're able to comment on them on our
Instagram on our YouTube channel and on
our Tick Tock make sure you're following
us on those platforms
don't forget that the best way to
support the David Pacman show is by
becoming a member which gives you access
to the Daily bonus show The Regular Show
with no commercials you also get access
to our entire Archive of every episode
dating back a really long time and
plenty of other awesome membership perks
go to joinpakman.com joinpakman.com
let's now continue our conversation with
renowned biologist Richard Dawkins a
conversation we started yesterday on the
program the full video discussion is
available on our YouTube channel at
youtube.com slash the David Pacman show
and speaking of which you mentioned
moving in the right direction
um Stephen Pinker and others have been
criticized for laying out the
perspective that by applying some very
uh um objective measures uh infant
mortality life expectancy likelihood of
dying in a war Etc that it number of
people living in abject poverty that
things are better than ever and one of
the um big counterpoints to that has
been while that may be true
our standards and expectations for
particularly Western democracies and
Rich Nations should have actually been
raised so dramatically that it's not
necessarily the big win someone like
Pinker points out to say okay there's
fewer people living on the equivalent of
a dollar a day now that we're actually
failing to solve solvable problems
hunger for example or whatever the case
may be is your view more in One
Direction or the other or more in
between a balanced View
is the Point you're making that it's the
danger of becoming complacent because of
um a book like pinker's saying things
are getting better therefore we don't
need to to work to make them even better
still is that I I don't know that that's
my argument but I'm I'm sort of
um voicing those who say that the
measures may not actually be the right
measures for how we evaluate how well
things are going for Homo sapiens are on
planet Earth
well I think we obviously need to try to
make things better still but I think
um Stephen pinker's one of his main
points is that we are so pessimistic and
the kind of thing that gets reported as
news is always bad news and and you
never get a a news headline that that
says something positive because it's
kind of boring it's not not a thing that
journalists are interested in yeah I'm
on a list of good news stories and very
often you can look at them and say
that's great news it will never get
attention because it's usually something
along the lines of uh breast cancer
survivability over the last 15 years has
increa increased 38 percent that's
extremely tangible meaningful for uh
people who get sick and their families
and love it's extraordinarily meaningful
and it makes a terrible news headline
for for-profit media
I mean one reason for that is that it's
not a sudden thing it's a it's it's a
it's a it's a gradual Trend yes um and
it I suppose if there were a sudden
breakthrough a sudden discovery that
that made breast cancer survival
dramatically improve on overnight then I
I guess that would count as news
when it comes to uh more specifically
now in terms of progress versus
regression the threat of Christian
nationalism uh in the United States and
around the world and this group that
well maybe 30 years ago they felt the
same way they were a little more Coy and
Slick about how they expressed it where
now we actually have elected officials
in the United States who openly say this
should be a Christian Nation Christian
nationalism is correct the Christian
doctrine should actually determine civil
government and how our society is
organized has your view of the threat of
that movement intensified since you
wrote for example The God Delusion
I am a distant Observer of the American
scene and I and I noticed that um people
that the Christian nationalists you're
talking about simply lie about the uh
Constitution and about the um intentions
of the founding fathers they do
absolutely clear that that they are
telling untruths
um it's it's very different over here of
course because we we genuinely are I
mean in Britain we are
founded in in Christianity in the sense
that the
um well the Monarch is the head of the
Church of England for example
um this is a historical accident it has
an utterly paradoxical effect which is
that it kind of makes religion boring
it's it's not a it's not a big problem
in the way that it is in America I think
precisely because in America
um
is not an established religion it's it's
something that's open to free enterprise
to to
um compete over therefore religion is
kind of exciting you have church these
great big churches with people waving
their arms around and dancing and things
we don't have that here not much anyway
and I think it's partly because we do
have an established
Church
yeah you know when I speak to my Italian
friends they are always very quick to
say oh no no no our elected officials
are Catholic I'm Catholic my family's
Catholic and when you probe a little bit
about what that means for their beliefs
and their everyday life
it means very little in the way of
policy making the way that it does in
the United States and I believe also if
you if you said to them do you actually
believe in the transubstantiation do you
actually believe that the wine becomes
the blood of Christ they probably don't
they probably don't even realize what it
is to be Catholic they just they're born
Catholic they're baptized Catholic
they're confirmed Catholic and so they
think they are Catholic but they don't
really believe it in that sense as
someone who's been a very strong critic
of organized religion do you find that
version for example of Catholicism that
I describe or what you're describing in
England is it relatively benign or is it
only benign in that it's not really the
type of religion in that that it
sometimes claims to be like you're
saying it's not maybe really Catholicism
I think it is relatively benign when I
stress the word relatively
um I mean when you think of the
competition when you think of Islam
um I I'm sometimes inclined to agree
with ion hercyali that that in certain
parts of the world at least we need
Christianity as a sort of buttress
against against something worse and
Hillary bellox line always keep a hold
of nurse for fear of finding something
worse I mean Christianity is bad enough
but it's not the worst religion around
is that is is that clear in your mind
this sort of ranking of the risk posed
by different religions
I think it is pretty clear I mean
Christianity was so appalling in the
Middle Ages and and um it's kind of had
a few centuries to grow up
and so I think that there is a
possibility of ranking there yes
do you I mean what is that what does
that landscape look like to you
well I mean it's one of the doctrines of
Islam that the penalty for apostasy is
death
well that's I think even the most
fervent Christian nationalist wouldn't
couldn't wouldn't say that somebody who
renounces Christianity should be killed
no I've had Christians on my show who
say gays should be killed which I don't
know if it's better or worse
it's about equally bad but I would say
so but um but it that's not that's not a
religion anyway well it may be it may be
fermented by religion but it's not
actually saying if you give up
Christianity you should be killed no
that's certainly true
do you think that I mean you know what
whenever this conversation is had
someone will invariably say oh well what
about Buddhism here's a bunch of very
peaceful things about Buddhism and then
someone will come back and say well okay
but then here's some other stuff about
Buddhism that maybe is actually a little
more concerning do you do you concern
yourself with looking into the details
of some of these smaller religions
relatively and going down the list
further and further or is that concern I
haven't really done much of that no I
don't I I I'm not that Keen on giving a
kind of rank order Fair no I think I had
that I think that that's fair
um let's talk about one more general
area in the time that uh that that we
have left uh you've said many things
over the last two years related to the
discussion about uh gender and
transgender and gender identity Etc some
of which you've said that I agree with
and some of which you've said that that
maybe I agree with a little less one of
the most in interesting things that I
heard over the last few months was Neil
deGrasse Tyson in a conversation with a
right-wing person from the United States
say listen
um there are all sorts of of
conversations and debates to be had
about this issue and the connection to
whether it's mental illness or whether
it's age appropriateness of certain
decisions that are made Etc can we all
agree that gender is expressed on a
spectrum and what I found interesting
about Neil deGrasse Tyson saying this is
that it's less a conversation about
biology and sex and genitalia but it is
a question about what I think is an
undeniable reality about about the world
which is at minimum the expression of
gender is on a spectrum and that maybe
that can serve as a starting point for
some of these discussions would you
agree with that which seems to me like
an uncontroversial statement or is that
a problematic statement to you I'm a
biologist and what I really object to is
the subversion of language talking about
a woman's penis
sorry for for example I mean that is
just
playing around playing fast and loose
with the English language
and um I'm I'm I'm a biologist who who
needs to talk about sex and the
difference between male and female which
is absolutely clear it's one of the very
few binaries we actually have
in biology I mean race is not a binary
race is a genuine Continuum obviously
because of false hybridization and so on
um almost everything else you can think
of is a Continuum short versus tall fat
versus thin
um all those things are are a Continuum
sex is the one thing which actually is a
binary
and
um I think that uh messing around with
the English language and well any
language for that matter to speak
English
um is a subversion a perversion of
clarity of thought Clarity of speech for
political ends yeah and I think most of
my Progressive colleagues would agree
that the the biological circumstances
undeniably are men women some percentage
born intersex and that's tiny tiny yes
no need to exaggerate what the
percentages
is it also in your mind a problem to
separate biological sex and gender
expression do you have an issue language
aside is that a concern to you
I am not particularly bothered if
somebody wants to present themselves as
the opposite of the sex that they are I
do object if they insist that other
people
recognize that and I mean I I support
Jordan Peterson in this if nothing else
that he objects to the Canadian
government making it mandatory that he
should call People by a pronoun like
they
um when they are I mean he's he's
prepared to do that as a matter of
courtesy but not as a matter of
compulsion and I thoroughly support him
on that you know I don't have the bill
in front of me but when I looked at it
18 months ago I struggled to find
anywhere where he talks about threat of
jail if you use the wrong pronoun I did
not find that but since I don't have it
in front of me maybe we'll we'll table
the those particulars
um but that being said what about for
example things like arresting doctors
who provide certain
um gender affirming care as it's called
maybe you have an issue with the term or
or not but what about the arresting of
doctors for example does that not start
to bite a little bit too
have doctors been arrested for that no
these are bills that have been proposed
in the United States it has not happened
to my knowledge fortunately
uh children or adults we've seen both in
different states
well I would have
um I would have a strong objection to
doctors
um uh
injecting
miners children
or performing surgery on on them to
change their sex
and as far as adults you have no issue
well
um
I think if if it's if if they've thought
about it properly like
um some like
um John Morris for example who I read
years ago one of the first of the trans
people that I read and greatly respected
her
her struggle that she went through in
order to
um change sex from male to female she
really really put herself through it and
clearly sincere clearly suffered from
from gender dysphoria no doubt about
that and and I take my hat off to her
and to the doctors who helped her but I
fear that what we're seeing now is a
fashion a craze
um a a a memeatic epidemic
um which is which is which is
spreading like an epidemic of of measles
or something like that
yeah I mean listen obviously we're not
going to resolve this today but I I
think you know I share some of the
concerns I've seen you share with regard
to uh children with regard to questions
about some of these treatments
Etc and I think that these should all be
questions that should be had and asked
and answered in good faith with data and
empiricism and I also can't help but see
that trans people and also trans kids
have become a very ugly scapegoat of a
movement that 15 years ago was mostly
targeting gay men and so my desire would
be and you tell me if you think it's
possible that we can ask all of these
questions in good faith while making it
clear we're not looking to discriminate
against individuals subject them to
whatever it was that other groups were
previous subjected to and hopefully get
to a place of understanding but
unfortunate do you agree that this has
become a scapegoated group
I what I see is that there's a in effect
a war going on between between gay
people and trans people or at least not
trans people themselves but but trans
activists so I'm not I'm not sure that I
I follow that I think I think that
um I I have great sympathy and great
respect for gay people
and uh I I worry about the bullying that
goes on uh not by trans people
themselves or necessarily but by some of
the activists I mean there was somebody
in Britain I think just a couple of days
ago who stood up and made a speech he
was at a a trans person a man turned
turned woman who said if you see a turf
punch her in the face
oh so in other words you if I understand
correctly you have some concerns about
LGBT and whether or not trans really is
part of the LGB movement or something
different well I think there are there's
been a recent court case in in Britain
um where an LGB Lobby was fighting
against a t- Lobby
I'm not familiar with that case but I'm
aware of that disagreement certainly so
that is a concern to you yes interesting
um all right Richard Dawkins there
there's no appropriate time to cut a
conversation but let's cut it now
because we are at the end of our time we
will be linking to your uh to your
podcast I really appreciate your time
and insights and I know you're very busy
thank you very much
if you value what we do at the David
packman show remember to support us on
patreon go to patreon.com davidpackman
show where you can get access to behind
the scenes videos The Daily bonus show
the commercial free Daily Show as well
as special discounts on merch including
hats hoodies mugs and t-shirts you can
support the show for as little as two
dollars a month check it out at
patreon.com davidpackman show Donald
Trump's lawyers want one of his criminal
trials postponed indefinitely why not
right I mean shoot your shot you you
miss a hundred percent of the shots you
don't take obviously this is Bonkers and
as usual they are they're they're
justifying this request by saying we
can't have this interfering with his run
for president it's a form of election
interference it's potentially uh
prejudicial to have this criminal trial
related to the documents going on while
Trump is President what's funny is this
is when while Trump is running for
president when Trump was President they
said no no no no there can't be any
investigations there can't be any
charges because Trump is President then
it was well this is a former president
then we can't do that either because of
convention or because of law now it's
he's a candidate once again so we also
can't do it and we all know that if by
some horrible situation Trump ends up
president again then they will say well
you can't have the sitting president on
trial so we have to postpone it again
the New York Times has a good write-up
about this a trump lawyers seek
indefinite postponement of documents
trial imagine if others not in positions
of power like Trump could do that you
know
I get it charges due diligence and
you've got the evidence and Witnesses
grand jury can we just like postpone
this thing forever maybe until after I'm
dead the article goes on the former
president's legal team argued in a court
filing that no trial date should be set
until all substantive motions in the
case were resolved setting up an early
key decision by judge Eileen Cannon
remember that judge Eileen Cannon is a
trump appointee and is a subject of
controversy in this entire thing the
written filing was submitted 30 minutes
before the deadline is an early test for
judge Cannon the Trump appointed jurist
who is overseeing the case if granted
this is a big key if granted it could
have the effect of pushing Trump's trial
into the final stages of the
presidential campaign
in which Trump is now the front runner
or even past the election now of course
then they would just come up with some
other reason why it should be postponed
again uh New York Times writing while
timing is important in any criminal
matter it could be hugely consequential
in Trump's case in which he stands
accused of illegally holding on to 31
classified documents after leaving the
White House and obstructing the
government's repeated efforts to reclaim
them there could be complications of A
Sort never before presented to a court
if Trump is a candidate in the last legs
of a presidential campaign and a Federal
Criminal defendant on trial at the same
time let me say something about that
Trump and his supporters are saying this
is that this is great look at what they
are doing to him they're trying to put
him on trial while he's running for
president
this is not the Justice uh systems doing
this is Trump's doing Trump is the one
who engaged in the alleged actions for
which he's now been charged Trump is the
one who said I'm going to run again
despite knowing that this may be coming
and the entire cloud above his head this
is all because of trump not because of
the justice system that has no choice
but to react to Trump but they're always
going to paint him as a victim
um another interesting paragraph some of
the former presidents advisors have been
blunt in private conversations that he
is looking to winning the election as a
solution to his legal problems and the
request for an open-ended delay to the
trial of trump and his co-defendant
presents a high-stakes question for
judge Cannon who came into the case
already under scrutiny for making
decisions favorable to the former
president in the early phases Trump's
lawyers pitched their request to Canon
as a plea for cautious deliberation and
as a means to safeguard democracy so of
course they want to make the argument
that if Trump Trump is forced to go to
trial it really endangers democracy and
as usual we're talking about projection
here because it is Trump's presidency
which endangered democracy it was
Trump's inciting of a riot to try to
prevent the guy who won from becoming
president that endangered democracy it
was Trump's supporters on January 6 2021
who endangered democracy the danger to
democracy is not Trump being held
accountable but that's what they want
you to believe last thing I want to
mention about this Law and Order right
due process is what they always argue
for and then they say postpone my trial
indefinitely there is a real possibility
that this reeks complete and total havoc
on Trump's campaign and as I said before
I don't see a path for Ron DeSantis to
winning this nomination unless something
very significant happens to Trump that
significant thing could be getting
charged a third or a fourth or A fifth
or more recently now we we wonder a
sixth time I don't think it will really
end up being six but it certainly could
be three four or even five uh that is
what DeSantis is waiting around for the
other possibility is the very end of a
presidential campaign uh either the
primary or the general where Trump can't
go to a debate because he has a court
date or some similar situation and it
would be unprecedented but it would not
be because Trump is the victim it would
be because Trump is the alleged
perpetrator and that's important to
remember if you want people to vote for
you you might not want to say that their
state is a disgrace a complete and total
softball Trump interview went horribly
wrong were Trump called Nevada
disgraceful when he was asked about hey
you lost twice what's your plan to win
in 2024. this is so endlessly
fascinating Trump was interviewed by the
uh this is called the Nevada Globe okay
the Nevada Globe the globe interview of
President Donald Trump I encourage you
to look at all of this the picture of
trump sitting there on a podcast
interview while they were with him is
really really wild stuff it's a lot this
is a transcript okay this is a text
interview there's a fascinating section
I want to focus in on the interviewers
say to Trump so let's talk Nevada
Governor Lombardo lost Clark County by
six points he lost Washoe County by two
points yet he's still won the
governorship additionally he's recently
signed legislation that Awards 25
million dollars to The Culinary Union
the Nevada Republican party believes
that that money is going to be used for
ballot harvesting proponents claim it's
going to be used for a capital
Improvement project that hasn't been
identified a Republican presidential
candidate hasn't won Nevada since 2004
you lost Nevada twice how do you win
Nevada
look at Trump's answer
I think I won the last time I think I
won both times by a lot this is a state
that is disgraceful
listen you lost twice here how are you
going to turn it around how are you
going to win this state is an absolute
disgrace vote for this man right away I
mean just not even passing the sniff
test for what is going to help him and
Trump goes on to say you know we sued on
the basis of they robbed the vote at a
level we had a lawsuit that was so good
and the judge didn't want to see it he
didn't even want to see it we had a
lawsuit that was in my opinion
conclusive but you know we have guys
like laxalt lack salt was a very weak
candidate he was pathetic you know I
helped laxalt do the best he could I
guess his grandfather was strong his
father was good but I guess the chain
got weaker and weaker remember the
question was how are you going to win
Nevada after losing it twice Trump's
talking about nonsense
um but Adam laxalt is a stiff and he
didn't do the job he was a lawyer he was
working for a lot of different people on
trying to do the vote thing but he
wasn't the right guy when you see
Trump's words as a transcript they are
10 times nuttier and more meaningless
Trump going on we have great people
working now we have great lawyers
working they used kobit to cheat the
last time they used covid to cheat but
we think we have a great team in place
to stop it we are then asked to wrap the
interview
um okay and then they they go on to talk
talk to Trump a little bit more
um this it's beyond parody really it's
be when he's asked about the fact that
he lost and how will you win he insists
I actually won I actually love the
transcript of the Trump interview I
think it's a great thing because it
really makes it for people who read
right who know how to read it makes the
statements even more meaningless where
he just sort of trails off and skips
around from one topic to another so
Trump's strategy to win Nevada is going
to be
um it is
calling the state a disgrace insisting
he actually won even though he lost
and I guess saying that they're gonna
fix it by something related to ballot
harvesting not a winning strategy in
Nevada my bets on Joe Biden in Nevada if
if I'm totally honest with you but we
hope we will have to wait and see we
have a voicemail number that number is
2192 David P often we get political
questions or commentary sometimes I get
praise we often get criticism for things
I didn't actually say but today's
voicemail is particularly weaponized
I would maybe say get the kids out of
the room I don't know let's take a
listen your show blows dude your show
blows dude the height
of political criticism your show blows
dude your show blows dude I'm convinced
that you are paid propaganda you're
always just
an echo chamber of the main lame stream
media paid by by whom exactly
every time this comes up I always
welcome
people who want to tell me exactly who
is paying me I mean people in the
audience are paying oh the bonus show
where you want to make money everybody
else it makes money to fund themselves
as bad sure people who like this enough
to pay for it or paying for it but who's
who's doing the paying actually you
don't bring any new ideas to the
table you talk to your people like
they're all stupid children and you're
like well sadly some of the people in
the comments
behave like stupid children and so I do
have to explain simple Concepts to them
that's that's an unfortunate reality
it's not the vast majority of the
audience but there are some that do need
things explained to them like their kids
on them how they should feel and I think
it's funny that
that you you
think people are that dumb that they
can't see right through that I know that
some of the people that uh comment on my
my content are that dumb I've been
seeing their thousands of comments a
month for years
I mean some of the people are dumb
enough to believe you but most people
see right through your
propaganda all right
yeah dude I I think that you're a paid
propagandist all right you mentioned
that paid by who
I'd love to debate you someday call in
anytime
because you contradict yourself over and
over when these folks say this there's
this implicit
allegation that I'm scared to debate
them
just call in I mean it's like I'm not
going to schedule a debate with you when
we take live calls on the Friday show
we're not screening for political
orientation I welcome Maga people
Republicans conservative Libertarians
who have a call in your white
nationalist you want to debate me call
in uh we're not screening the calls it's
because they don't call in that you're
not hearing them on the show not because
we're blocking them or whatever the case
may be so anyway wacky wacky stuff the
Department of Justice now says it no
longer deems Trump immune from a lawsuit
by E Gene Carroll we're going to talk
about what that means on today's bonus
show we're also going to talk about Bank
of America agreeing to pay to or being
ordered to pay 250 million dollars for
illegal fees and fake accounts this is
part Wells Fargo and part grift and I
actually have a lot of personal stories
to tell about Bank fees that may be
interesting to some of the audience we
are also going to talk about how the
Tommy tuberville uh situation is leaving
the Marine Corps without a permanent
leader and how if you believe in
supporting the military and you believe
in supporting our troops this is a very
unpatriotic thing to do all of those
stories and more will be on today's
bonus show you can get instant access to
the bonus show by simply signing up at
joinpakman.com super easy thing to do
in addition to that you can use the
coupon code 24 starts now or indict it
again or indicated or sad Trump or any
of the coupon codes you can use any of
them to get instant access I'll see you
on the bonus show remember the
children's book is available at
davidpackman.com book and we'll be back
tomorrow this isn't the end for the week
we'll be back tomorrow very strongly
very powerfully if I have anything to
say about it
thank you
thanks a lot for watching Today's Show I
just want to take a second to tell you
about today's sponsors it is hard to
find comfortable t-shirts shirts made of
supima cotton are the softest you will
find under one percent of t-shirts are
made with supima cotton and Leisure of
NYC is the place to find them you'll get
15 off their silky smooth t-shirts and
boxers at davidpackman.com
NYC the link is down below